a licensed practical nurse who was in
charge of caring for severely disabled
patient is now accused of raping her she
gave birth to a baby boy nearly four
weeks ago investigators arrested 36 year
old Nathan Sutherland and charged him
with sexual assault and vulnerable adult
abuse Carter Evans is at Hacienda
Healthcare that's in Phoenix where
southern worked Carter a lot of people
glad there wasn't arrest in this case
good morning to you a lot of people
paying attention to this one sutherland
worked here from 2011 until his arrest
on tuesday now the victim's family has
asked for privacy but they say the 29
year old is not in a coma she's capable
of some movement and she responds to
sound they say she likes it when people
read to her mr. Sutherlin you're here on
one count sex assault across Nathan
Sutherlin appeared in a Phoenix
courtroom Wednesday to face charges of
sexual assault in vulnerable adult abuse
police say the licensed practical nurse
raped the patient and got her pregnant
she'd been in hussy into health care
since she was three years old we owed
this arrest to the victim we owed this
the rest to the newest member of our
community
that innocent baby police were first
alerted in December when a staff member
called 9-1-1 one of the stadium you had
no idea she was pregnant ultimately
investigators asked for DNA samples from
male employees of the facility including
Sutherland did he cooperate initially
when he was asked to give a sample my
understanding is that he gave the DNA
sample after he found that there was a
court order which compelled him to give
that he did not volunteer to give a DNA
sample
I was shocked cuz I knew who the hell
this guy was Karina Scecina who says
Sutherland worked overnights moved her
daughter from hacienda after she found
out about the incident anything about
his demeanor that stands out no I didn't
think of anything about it I didn't
notice anything I didn't suspect
anything until I saw this picture and
then I was like oh I'm talking to a
possible rapist in a statement Hacienda
health care officials say Sutherland
went through an extensive background
check when he was hired and they added
their trouble beyond words to think that
a licensed practical nurse could
be capable of seriously harming a
patient advocates for long-term care
oversight are calling for action
due diligence needs to be done by the
facilities as their hiring staff there
needs to be better monitoring of staff
in terms of making sure that residents
are protected it really does put us all
on notice now police say Sutherland has
no criminal record Hacienda here has
increased security the CEO here has
resigned along with a doctor and another
doctor has been suspended
an attorney for Sutherland says he's
entered not guilty pleas and he's going
to get his own DNA test John all right
Carter thank you